the reality television series american
pickers has been a constant presence on
history's programming schedule for over
a decade
and remains a fan favorite show to this
day
finally i catch a break since the series
premiere
in january 2010 the stars of american
pickers have traveled near and far
searching the united states for valuable
pieces of history housed in shacks
sheds shops storage containers and more
considering that there's plenty of
territory the stars haven't covered in
the show's 22 seasons
it stands to reason that american
pickers could last another decade or
more
on the air of course that depends on
whether or not the network and the
series trio of hosts
mike wolf frank fritz and danielle colby
choose to stick around however based on
the most recent batch of episodes
that may not be the case wolf and colby
were back in action
for more antiquing adventures but when
american pickers premiered its 22nd
season in january 2021
fritz was nowhere to be found he was
also absent for the show's mid-season
return
on june 7th which got fans talking
discussion about fritz's crohn's disease
diagnosis
which explains his recent weight loss
prevailed in some circles
while others pointed to jersey john
taking his place as a sign
that fritz's american picker's tenure
could be coming to an
end no no no here's what we know about
frank fritz's
american pickers status while there
isn't a ton of concrete information out
there about why fritz has been missing
from recent episodes
outlets like celeb hook are claiming
that there are a few factors preventing
his immediate return
first and foremost covet 19 is still a
problem and since fritz is someone with
a serious pre-existing medical condition
risking catching the virus is surely
something he would want to avoid
neither fritz nor anyone part of the
american pickers team
have confirmed this as a reason for
fritz's absence but a press release
issued ahead of the show's arrival in
missouri in may 2021
reveals that the cast and crew are
taking things seriously regarding
covid19 safety
the press release reads in part we
understand that with the proliferation
of covet 19
we are all facing very uncertain times
we at american pickers are taking the
pandemic
very seriously and will be following all
guidelines and protocols for safe
filming as outlined
by the state and cdc the us son has also
claimed that fritz was quarantining in
iowa where he recently sold his and his
ex-fiance's home
it's also worth mentioning that mike
wolf has acknowledged fritz's
disappearance with reality tidbit
reporting wolves's announcement that
fritz underwent back surgery for an
undisclosed reason
over on the american pickers facebook
page one fan confirmed in a comment
under a photo post in march 2021 frank's
absence has been addressed
in a past episode frank had back surgery
he's recovering
the commenter added that in a later
episode frank's name was mentioned twice
which should be proof that he in their
words obviously hasn't been cut
out of the show though it's unclear what
fritz had surgery for
some types of operations on the back or
spine can require a lengthy recovery
period
according to neurosurgeons of new jersey
patients spend at least one day
often more in the hospital immediately
after surgery then endure between
six to eight weeks and several months of
recovery patients will likely begin
physical therapy
one to three months following surgery
and that the frequency
intensity and overall duration of
therapy sessions differs depending on
the type of surgery the patient had
and their surgeon's recommendations
having and recovering from back surgery
managing crohn's disease selling a house
and avoiding catching and spreading
covid19
would overwhelm just about anyone and
frank fritz
is likely no exception i need a break
with covet 19 vaccination numbers
soaring
according to bloomberg news and mask
mandates being slowly rolled back as
well
hopefully fritz will feel more
comfortable hitting the road with his
longtime co-host
mike wolf and digging through america's
biggest treasure troves
in the near future check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one